[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans le 7-8
journal de tv 78 c'est l'essentiel de
l'actualité locale tout de suite les
titres de ce mardi 29 janvier la tempête
gabriel va toucher l'ile-de-france et
les yvelines le département est placé en
alerte orange neige et verglas à partir
de 19 heures jusqu'à 15 15 centimètres
de neige pourraient tomber localement
avec de fortes rafales de vent
le plan sur les conditions et les
possibles conséquences dans ce journal
nous serons notamment depuis la
nationale 10 à trappes est depuis le 1er
janvier la réforme est en place ma peau
et prélever directement à la source vous
l'avez sûrement constaté sur votre fiche
de paye de janvier hier le secrétaire
d'état olivier du soft est venu à
rambouillet pour échanger sur le sujet
avec les chefs d'entreprises et la
visite est également le centre drapeau
de la ville
et puis le grand débat national se met
en place dans les yvelines une vingtaine
de réunions est programmée dans le
département d'ici le 15 mars une grande
majorité est des communes a choisi
d'ouvrir en mairie des cahiers de
doléances invités de ce journal philippe
g selon maire de méricourt et président
de l'association des maires ruraux des
yvelines
la neige déjà de retour dans le
département une semaine après le premier
épisode avec la tempête gabriel qui
devrait toucher le territoire dès ce
soir on retrouve tout de suite au bord
de la nationale 10 manon varaldo
accompagné de patrick jacques de dixmude
bonsoir le département manon placer ce
soir en vigilance orange
oui grégory une alerte orange aux vents
neige et verglas lancé à 19 heures et
qui s'étend jusqu'à demain matin 6h
vous le voyez derrière moi je me trouve
actuellement sur la n118
les automobilistes ont anticipé et
souhaite rentrer plus tôt à leur
domicile tout comme la nationale 10 les
grands axes sont interdits à tous les
poids lourds également la nationale 118
est coupée dans les deux sens et ce
depuis cet après midi 15 heures
elle rouvrira demain en milieu
matinée rappelons-nous l'année dernière
des centaines d'automobilistes avaient
été bloqués sur la nationale 118 en
raison de la neige
la ministre des transports elisabeth
bornes appelle les automobilistes à la
plus grande vigilance à s'informer
impérativement des conditions
climatiques et de circulation avant de
prendre la route et à se conformer
strictement aux consignes des autorités
locales
la préfecture des yvelines invite
également à limiter ses déplacements et
dans la mesure du possible à privilégier
les transports en commun mais je précise
manon vous êtes bien en direct depuis la
nationale 10 au niveau de trappe alors
une alerte orange prévue ce soir alerte
orange neige et verglas dans le
département comment va évoluer la
situation manon alors pour le moment
nous avons quelques gouttes de pluie
mêlée à de la neige mais la situation
devrait évoluer puisque cette neige
devrait tenir au sol dès 22h ce soir la
tempête gabriel se renforcera encore
dans la soirée et dans la nuit
météo france annonce des cumuls de neige
qui devront aller de 5 à 10 cm et
partiellement jusqu'à 15 cm de neige en
plus de la neige du vent et des rafales
jusqu'à 70 5 80 kilomètres heure selon
les zones sont à craindre
cette nuit en conséquence les risques
d'accident sont accrus
quelques dégâts pourraient affecter les
réseaux de distribution d'électricité et
de téléphonie la soirée et la nuit
promettent d'être blanche dans les
yvelines soyez donc vigilants surtout si
vous devez vous déplacer
merci manon pour ces précisions
accompagner pour les moyens techniques
de patrick jacques de dixmude et autre
conséquence de cette alerte à la neige
et au verglas les transports scolaires
seront interdits demain sur l'ensemble
du département des yvelines certains
établissements scolaires ont même prévu
de rester fermés ce mercredi dans
certaines villes un service d'accueil
minimum sera proposée pour les enfants
c'est le cas à plaisir pour les jeunes
inscrits aux accueils de loisirs et sur
les temps d'activités périscolaires et
puis autre conséquence de ces conditions
météo des événements prévus ce soir sont
annulées
exemple avec la nuit des métiers et de
l'orientation ce soir à montigny
bretonneux qui est reporté et pour être
informés sur les différentes
conséquences dans vos communes rendez
vous sur les sites internet pour faire
face à ce nouvel épisode de neige les
collectivités sont sur le pied de guerre
à saint-quentin-en-yvelines des
opérations de salage ont débuté dès cet
après midi 16 heures sur les axes
départementaux le service hivernal est
assurée en commun par les yvelines et
des hauts-de-seine 159 agents sont
mobilisés sur les 1600 kilomètres de
voies et les engins de salage qui sont
sorties elle dit la nuit dernière la
nuit prochaine s'annonce également animé
pour le service le point sur la
situation avec morgane sanchez elle est
directrice adjointe est du service
interdépartemental de la voirie
interrogé par me marie lehn iapichino
l'ensemble des équipes sont mobilisées
donc l'ensemble des équipes ça fait
quarante six agents sur les deux
départements
on a trente deux saleuses qui sont
prévues et qui sont prêtes à sortir et à
intervenir et pour la venue de ce soir
on a également mobilisé les agriculteurs
pour le réseau secondaire pour qu'ils
puissent intervenir si vraiment en été
dans la fourchette haute des estimations
qui sont annoncés donc plutôt sur 15 cm
de neige
en fait on réagira vraiment en fonction
de l'intensité du phénomène donc mais
qui va se mettre à neiger les véhicules
vont sortir vont déneiger avec les lames
ce qui est tombé et puisse aller
derrière en préventif pour que la neige
accroche moins facilement et qu'il ait
pas de phénomène de verglas
et j'ajoute qu'un centre opérationnel
sera activé dès 19h et le service de
voirie yvelines hauts de seine qui se
tient après est en tout cas qu'ils
pourraient être mobilisés toute la nuit
si le phénomène s'avère important avec
nous un plateau en invité philippe
ghislain bon fort dans sa tête le maire
de méricourt président également de
l'association des maires ruraux des
yvelines
juste avant de parler du grand débat
national ce pourquoi vous êtes venus ce
soir comment une une petite commune des
yvelines comme mary course se prépare à
un tel phénomène hélas dès cet après
midi nous avons remonté la saleuse et
préparer le bras pour mettre la la lame
sur notre unique unique tracteur
communal
on a une opération de salage en cours à
l'employé communal est en train de faire
un salage préventif et dès demain matin
à 5 heures j'ai rendez vous avec lui
pour faire le point de la situation et
nous organiser pour déneiger nos routes
afin que nos concitoyens puissent partir
travail dans de bonnes conditions c'est
toujours un moment redouté pour les
communes rurales ce genre d'épisode
neigeux avec les conséquences que cela
peut impliquer notamment des des pannes
d'électricité aussi des conditions de
circulation difficiles aussi c'est
surtout que le salage c'est quelque
chose d'assez délicat à un degré près
c'est inefficace
donc là on a fait un préventif pour ce
soir je pense que ça va éviter que ça
prenne trop trop vite au sol et donc
demain matin demain matin le des neiges
âge déneigement complet on a une chance
c'est qu'il aura pas de transports
scolaires dans notre commune puisque
c'est mercredi
ça c'est une bonne chose et on croise
les doigts pour qu'il ait pas de
coupures de courant bien évidemment
c'est de toute façon les les transports
scolaires seront totalement interdits
demain dans le département des yvelines
reste avec nous parle dans un instant du
grand débat national d'abord vous le
savez sans doute depuis ce 1er janvier
elle les impôts sont prélevés à la
source c'est-à-dire directement sur vos
salaires une réforme qui a été longue à
mettre en place a expliqué le secrétaire
d'état auprès du ministre de l'action et
des comptes publics olivier du soft est
venu échangé hier avec les chefs
d'entreprises yvelinois une visite à
rambouillet tu le reportage de marie
lehn yapi shiloh un échange pour
rassurer le secrétaire d'état auprès du
ministre de l'action et des comptes
publics a répondu à l'invitation de la
députée aurore bergé a rencontré des
chefs d'entreprise de pme et tpe
elvinois il y a un nom les inquiétudes
étaient fortes et le président de la
république avait pris la décision de
reporter la mise en oeuvre du
prélèvement à la source
ça nous a laissé un an pour finaliser
cette réforme fait en sorte que
techniquement les choses fonctionnent
bien
de mieux communiquer avec les chefs
d'entreprise et avec les contribuables
je pense que c'est très important de
pouvoir avoir des échanges concrets sur
les lois qui ont été votées qui sont en
application pour voir concrètement
comment elles sont mises en deux les
chefs d'entreprise présents salue
l'initiative
la réforme est bien acceptée et ils ont
eu le temps de communiquer avec leurs
salariés
ils ont cependant pu aborder certains
points de complication pour les petites
toutes les petites entreprises ont été
vus par exemple il ya un coût pour le
dirigeant qui doit s'impliquer
énormément recevoir ses salariés des
rassurer mais un coup aussi parce que le
soya surcoût pour les fiches de paye que
les cabinets d'expertise-comptable
facture aujourd'hui lorsqu'un salarié
arrive en cours de mois enfin voilà son
premier mois de gauche on lui met une
moyenne donc il faudrait une réactivité
de la la fiscalité pour pouvoir remettre
à niveau par rapport à son salaire
justement le prélèvement olivier dussopt
up s'est ensuite rendu au centre des
impôts de rambouillet les fonctionnaires
lui ont expliqué comment ils
accompagnent les administrés dans
l'application de cette réforme
ici la personne à contacter le service
des impôts via une messagerie
son taux est modifié en quelques clics
par l'administratrice n'est vraiment
très très reconnaissant à l'ensemble des
agents des services fiscaux depuis le 2
janvier le service géré son impôt à la
source sur le site internet
impots.gouv.fr et 4 millions de visites
et une autre nouveauté de janvier bien
sûr c'est le début de ce grand débat
national pour répondre à la crise des
gilet jaune rappelle que nous avons avec
nous en plateau philippe g selon vous
êtes le maire de méricourt est également
président de l'association des maires
ruraux des yvelines vous avait
d'ailleurs choisi de vous associer à ce
grand débat national vous allez nous
dire dans un instant pourquoi déjà un
premier bilan deux semaines après sa
mise en place que vous devez vous avez
l'impression qu'il intéresse des
français ce grand débat national
oui de plus en plus ils intéressent les
français je pense qu'ils intéressent
aussi des élus de plus en plus son va
tout de suite après les cahiers de
doléances on a réuni
nous on a réuni les maires ruraux mais
on a senti les élus un petit peu frileux
quant à l'organisation de ce grand débat
d'avoir ce que des élus se sentait pas
tous en capacité d'animer ce genre de
réunions vous avez peur un peu de vous
êtes face à une fronde et et puis petit
à petit bain on regarde de ce qui se
passe au national tout simplement des
des grands débats qui est à des réunions
grands débats qui ont déjà eu lieu
mes collègues et moi même sommes mis
autour d'une table pour savoir comment
on allait organiser ça et je pense que
ça va être quelque chose d'intéressant
et le fait par exemple que edouard
philippe soit venu assister à un grand
débat sur la commune de sartrouville
vendredi dernier est ce que c'est une
bonne initiative de sa part de venir
expliquer directement face aux yvelinois
ce grand débat et les thématiques qui
sont débattues ouais je pense que chacun
doit jouer son rôle dans ce dans ce
débat je pense que c'est
c'est une opportunité c'est une chance
pour le pays ça s'est jamais fait voilà
on doit nous on sera dans notre rôle
d'élu de proximité pour ouvrir nos
salles des fêtes d écouter nos
concitoyens puissent qui on va pas faire
du président mac rôle c'est d'être of
view vient des facilitateurs sonné voilà
on est plutôt organisateurs et
co-animateur l'idée c'est de
d'accompagner le maire organisateurs
d'être donc certainement moi je vais
essayer de m'en tous les cas moi d'aller
sur tout les treize réunions que j'ai
organisé
on a sollicité aussi notre député de la
9e circonscription qui va se rendre au
maximum disponible pour être présent il
s'agit pas là de répondre je vous dis en
direct aux questions mais mais plutôt de
d'être là pour orienter un peu le débat
est bien cadré pour se concentrer sur
l'essentiel le fait que ça soit unique
vous lui disiez que on donne la parole
aux français c'est ça aussi qui vous a
poussé à vous associez vous est aussi
l'ensemble des maires ruraux des
yvelines à ce grand débat oui oui oui
absolument on est dans la continuité de
ce qu'on a fait avec avec les cahiers de
doléances
vous étiez l'un des premiers maires en
tout cas la première association à
ouvrir les cahiers de doléances sur le
territoire des yvelines tout à fait nous
on souhaite on souhaite
voilà que d'abord que le pays sorte de
cette crise dans lequel il est plongé
depuis certainement trop longtemps on
souhaite faire émerger des nouvelles
idées accompagnez nos concitoyens je
pense que dans les revendications il ya
des ya aussi des bonnes idées j'en ai
rencontré un groupe i hier soir on a
beaucoup travaillé et je pense que voilà
il ya des choses qui vont qui vont
émerger on sait pas encore comme quelle
forme cela prendra par la suite ce qu'on
espère c'est que le président de la
république et le gouvernement en
tirerons les enseignements et prendront
des décisions et qui vont dans le bon
sens il ya une vingtaine de réunions
pour le moment organisées sur le
territoire des yvelines ça peut encore
évoluer
vous êtes à l'initiative de 2,15 réunion
c'est ça pour moi j'en ai 13-13 de
programmer entre l'association des
maires ruraux et des communes qui sont
pas forcément rural d'ailleurs ce soir
on démarre ce soir aux mureaux où j'irai
tout à l'heure et on a aussi bonnières
sur seine
on a préféré essayer de concentrer sur
les chefs lieux de canton des réunions
pour éviter d'avoir cette multiplication
de réunions d'une manière être avoir des
réunions ou regroupera un maximum un
maximum d'habitants et on va les ouvrir
bien sûr communes environnantes
vous pourriez y aborder tous les thèmes
ou seulement les quatre grands thèmes
qui ont été qui ont été fixés par le
président de la république
voilà c'est aussi une des particularités
nous on a choisi on a choisi d'ouvrir à
tous les thèmes bien sûr on va mettre à
disposition déjà à l'entrée de chaque
salle quatre cahiers sur les quatre
thèmes qui sont proposés par qui ont été
proposées par le président mais nous on
va dire ce qu'on veut c'est libérer la
parole on aura à un cahier de doléances
aussi 10 rappelle s'appellera autre sur
lequel on va on va recueillir toutes les
doléances et la difficulté pour nous ça
va être de retranscrire tout ce qui sera
dit lors de ces réunions ça va être un
gros travail donc on va on va on va
mettre du personnel à disposition
justement pour la salle de réunion sont
sur le site du grand débat national
elles sont référencés
chaque commune ses références et et va
nous en a mis également sur sur notre
page facebook de l'association des
maires ruraux des yvelines
je pense que notre député de la fait
aussi et on est en lien avec la
préfecture donc pour organiser toutes
ces réunions et on projette de faire une
synthèse dès la fin du mois de février
pour envoyer le résultat de de tout ce
travail puisque ça reste un travail
collectif
on voudrait que ça remonte le plus vite
possible au gouvernement
et toutes ces dates je le rappelle sont
à retrouver donc sur le site du grand
débat national qui a dû s'afficher au
cours de cet entretien merci philippe
gesland d'avoir été avec nous je
rappelle que vous êtes le maire de
méricourt est également le président de
l'association des maires ruraux les
yvelines merci d'être passé sur ce
plateau
il a présenté ses premiers voeux en tant
que maire de coignières didier fischer a
réuni les habitants de la commune
vendredi au salon antoine de
saint-exupéry élu en novembre à la tête
de la municipalité il a pu exposer au
cours de son discours les grands
dossiers de 2019 à lancement des
réhabilitation du gymnase et des écoles
développer la participation citoyenne
avec la création de conseils de quartier
l'édile en a profité également à
profiter de la présence de la députée
aurore bergé pour faire part d'une
volonté l'enfouissement de la route
nationale 10 au niveau de coignières et
didier fischer souhaite à l'inscription
du projet au prochain contrat de plan
etat-région 2020 2025 un enfouissement
qu'il espère voir d'ici les dix
prochaines années pour réunir les
quartiers de la commune
aujourd'hui coupé par la route nationale
on nous demande de faire 450 logements
on devra les faire en grande partie je
dirais dans le secteur de notre gars est
une obligation aux riffs
le problème c'est qu'on construit
quelque chose à côté et en terme de
circulation en termes de qualité de vie
c'est pas possible
l'enfouissement va nous permettre en
fait d'obtenir une bien meilleure
qualité de vie moins d'embouteillages
ensuite moins de délestage dans notre
dans notre ville une plus grande
fluidité en définitive de la circulation
une réunion de nos quartiers moins de
bruit moins de pollution coûté c'est je
dire on attend ça avec impatience et on
parlait du grand débat national
coignières a décidé également de
s'associer pleinement dans cette
initiative un cahier de doléances a été
ouvert en mairie et un débat se
déroulera le 13 mars prochain à la
maison de voisinage dans ce contexte
justement de grand débat national des
services de l'état dans le département
ont présenté leurs voeux
le préfet jean jacques brot a convié
plus de 700 personnes dans les locaux de
la préfecture à versailles en fin de
semaine dernière et des élus
parlementaires maires présents mais
aussi les représentants des différents
cultes religieux des entreprises et
associations
le préfet qui a avant tout formulé le
voeu de l'entraidé du dialogue dans le
département message visiblement entendu
du côté du président du sénat
l'yvelinois gérard larcher les
interviews sont recueillies ont été
recueillis par michael et demi d'euros
d'enthousiasmé si possible de fraternité
est un travail collectif comme je le dis
dans la fraternité républicaine c'est de
montrer que l'état est d'abord dans un
esprit de service au service du bien
commun dans la fraternité c'est ça que
nous voulions dire et essayer de
commencer à le démontrer relevé un
certain nombre de défis le défi de la
cohésion du développement économique du
vivre ensemble
c'est aujourd'hui ce que nous ressentons
de très profondément et ça doit être
possible
vu la qualité des relations
territoriales entre les services de
l'état
le conseil départemental et les 259
communes de ce département
c'est un nouveau fonctionnement pour eux
les collèges aux yvelinois depuis le 1er
janvier 2019 le conseil départemental
des yvelines a chargé le groupe sodexo 2
fournira les repas pour les cantines des
116 établissements non sans
dysfonctionnement certains parents et
élèves dénoncent une mauvaise qualité
des produits servis et notamment dans le
collège de la mauldre à maule
les explications de nicolas landry une
pétition avec 400 signatures et un
boycott de la cantine voilà la situation
au collège de la mauldre à maule
conséquence d'une baisse de la qualité
des repas selon les élèves pain congelé
des charançons dans les lentilles un
constat des élèves et de leurs parents
dont se défend le département chargé de
la gestion des collèges
quand un de vos confrères expliquent que
on a servi un enfant qui portent
témoignage du fait qu'on a servi des
lentilles charançonné lorsque le cuistot
s'est aperçu qu'il y avait des
charançons dans les lentilles
naturellement il les a pas servis donc
elles ne sont jamais arrivés sur la
table des enfants donc aucun appui à
manger face à ces dysfonctionnements le
conseil départemental des yvelines
plaide le temps d'adaptation face à ce
nouveau mode de fonctionnement
la sélection c'est notre associé donc la
sodexo ne peut pas ne pas remplir ce
pourquoi elle s'est associée avec nous
donc il n'y a aucune inquiétude
l'inquiétude n'est pas matériel nous
avons besoin de temporalité moi je pense
que fin février tout ça ne sera plus
qu'un mauvais souvenir
rires sachant que comme toujours dans
ces systèmes de restauration collective
y aura ici ou là des problèmes qui
resurgiront régulièrement et qu on
corrigera automatiquement
ce nouveau mode de fonctionnement passe
par la société d'économie mixte c midi
avec des obligations fixées par le
département à son partenaire la sodexo
suite à présent de notre dossier de la
rédaction cette semaine focus sur l'aide
et la solidarité dans le département ce
soir nous nous rendons à la balise qui
sait la boutique alimentaire de saint
quentin en yvelines depuis plus de 20
ans ces bénévoles s'occupent des
bénéficiaires habitant les communes de
guyancourt magny les hameaux montigny et
voisins le bretonneux une cinquantaine
de familles aidées chaque mois au total
le sujet de mélanie poké dieu
bon je vous donne la liste des produits
vous pouvez acheter chez nous comme
chaque jeudi
janick est à l'accueil de balises qui
depuis trois ans est bénévole explique
aux bénéficiaires leurs droits et
surtout prête une oreille attentive
on en profite pour aborder avec eux
leurs problèmes et les écouter essayer
de voir ce qu'on peut
comment on peut faire pour les aider il
ya un énorme besoin d' écoutes chez les
gens qu'on accueille ils ont besoin de
parler de leurs problèmes même si moore
pas leur trouver des solutions miracles
c'est évident de le fait d'en parler au
japon dans ses goûts bien 38 bénévoles
se relaient pour accueillir les 55
familles familles monoparentales chômage
ou baisse de revenus et les
bénéficiaires peuvent venir sur une
durée de trois à quatre mois
ils sont adressés par les services
sociaux de quatre communes
saint-quentinoise
en général quand elle gêne chez lui
c'est pas la première nécessité
ces familles qui ont un projet qui est
et revenant ici ça leur permet de je
dirais de réaliser ce projet et avec
l'ambition de s'en sortir alors sortir
de l'eau mais en les responsabilisant
sur leurs achats
et quand ils viennent chez nous ils ont
des montants d'achat qui leur sont
alloués on essaye de s'adapter à la
situation globale familial de la famille
des conditions de vie des conditions de
recherche d'emploi les enfants c'est
vrai qu'il ya beaucoup de paramètres qui
peuvent entrer en ligne de compte
de gaulle produits d'entretien
alimentaires ou d'hygiène balises qui
propose environ 300 références à prix
réduit un panier de 60 euros dans le
commerce vaut une trentaine d'euros
dans cette boutique on va les acheter
actuellement dans certains magasins on
est livré par d'autres on a d'autres qui
viennent par revivre éventuellement des
collectes puis ce qui nous arrive de
temps en temps de faire des deux femmes
est également chaque mois une commission
étudie les dossiers des demandeurs
l'association existe depuis maintenant
24 ans financé par les communes saint
quentin en yvelines le département et
des dons son budget est de 210 mille
euros vous avez entendu sa voix dans ce
reportage allez maintenant sur ce
plateau bonsoir mélanie poker sarthe
outre tout autre chose dès à présent
comme chaque mardi c'est le coup de
coeur culture
[Musique]
et cette semaine des rendez vous très
musicaux et oui il va falloir faire un
choix grégory car le week-end débute
très fort si rendez vous dès le vendredi
et cinq sont music hall a ravi les i
villacoublay
c'est un opéra qui vous attend est
l'espace fils noirs et des
clayes-sous-bois un concert classique
sous la conduite de marianne piketty et
à magny les hameaux c'est le jazz le
jazz de gastines malek qui vous
accompagnera appelé lyon sera plutôt
nostalgique et oui parmi ses plus grands
titres
l'école est finie vous les copains les
rois mages encore space à l'icône des
années yéyé en france sheila et sur la
scène du théâtre espace coluche ce
vendredi elle revient cette fois sur
scène accompagné du groupe pop-rock
hashtag pour une réorchestration de ses
plus grands films
[Musique]
b
je vais pas
tu me du mnb
et je tombe r
[Musique]
peu de musique du monde aussi et oui à
guyancourt cette fois ce sont les
rythmes jamaïcains qui vous attendent
alors il y aura trois groupes et
artistes qui vont se partager la scène
de la batterie route héritage lidge up
et gaëlle and roll dodge fellow
la soirée sera placée là sous le signe
du partage de la tradition et de la
musique live en ce sens
[Musique]
merci mélanie pour ce coup de coeur et
pour ne rien manquer des rendez vous est
réservé sa place direction kiosque point
est-ce qu y point fr ou votre émission
le 7-8 culture c'est après journal c'est
ça a retrouvé donc après ce journal
avant de se quitter une plongée dans le
vendée globe le navigateur versailles et
éric bellion a présenté à versailles son
film baptisé comme un seul homme qui
retrace son parcours en totale immersion
au sein de la compétition et miquel et
demi d'euros et patrick jacques de
dixmude l'ont rencontré un invité de
marque au cinéma ugc cyrano de
versailles le skipper versailles et éric
bellion est venu présenter en avant
première son film comme un seul homme le
long métrage d'une heure 25 autres à son
vendée globe 2010 est un tour du monde
en solitaire
donc c'est tout ce qui se passe quand on
perd le bateau de vue et jusqu'à ce
qu'on le redécouvre et donc c'est tout
ce cheminement intérieur le fait d'aller
au delà de sa peur de se rencontrer et
j'essaie de le raconter avec le plus de
sincérité possible je crois que des
moments très forts parce que ça c'est
une aventure ultime
moi j'avais jamais fait de solitaire
avant de partir sur le vendée globe
donc tout est une découverte chaque jour
est une aventure pour immerger au
maximum le public le skipper s'est filmé
pendant plus de cinquante heures à
l'aide d'une caméra miniature en
parallèle de ces manoeuvres dans les
bacs
j'ai pas ressenti le fait que cela me
prenne trop de temps c'est vraiment
quelque chose que je voulais donc
c'était pour moi aussi important que
bien faire marcher mon bateau et puis
j'avais des caméras facilement
atteignables donc je pouvais les
déclencher quand j'avais quelque chose à
dire ou quand je ressentais quelque
chose de fort je voulais vraiment
communiquer c'était très important pour
moi de le partager au maximum à la
sortie de ce film première réaction du
public versé y est c'est enfin c'est
quelqu'un d'assez original et je trouve
que c'est sympa de pouvoir nous faire
partager ce qu'il a vécu la difficulté
de la course comme ça c'est 2 c'est pas
partager ces moments là il a eu une
approche de ce tour du monde avec une
philosophie finalement sur sa façon
d'appréhender ces difficultés sa
relation avec son bateau sa relation de
la solitude ça me parle beaucoup
la sortie en salles officielle du film
est programmée le 13 février prochain
sur tout le territoire français
et c'est la fin de ce journal belle
soirée avec tv 78
[Musique]